so apparently there's one rule that you
have uniquely your the family's epa OU
do the taxes well turbo tax yeah in
turbotax so here's a candidate who says
trust me when i release my taxes
there'll be no problem yeah but he won't
say when or release him how much he'll
release well what's in them and that's
my fault he said to me we have to answer
this and i said well i was expecting
that when they would do we would be
releasing them and i was at the prior
years well sure i'll have to come back
and find them but yes are they they're
not on file anyway some of yeah they're
on file but we haven't been home for a
month right so two weeks ago people
asked the Clinton campaign or somebody
asked him we said oh of course will
release them and we will and in full not
a summary not an individual page that
whole thing no problem if Donald Trump
or some other candidate said trust me
I'll release them eventually trust me
would you say oh that's fine there's
nothing in them no problem where would
you say we really need to see this i
would say i would say well when they're
due I would expect them to come out now
if I have to tell you every other year I
asked for an extension but this year we
knew I couldn't do that Sam so you'll
release how many years I don't know how
many do you want mark but i think the
Clintons have released eight or even
more but at least they've been in office
all these years they've done it santer
está in the house incentive right and
when we we every election we've we've
released them so maybe that you or at
least you're whole returns not just the
summer we did in when he ran for
election yeah so alright we look forward
today i'll i'll release this year's as
soon as they're due and can I have time
to go home sure but you're saying
there's nothing nothing in them there's
nothing we're really pretty boring you
have your Senate didn't come what else
do you guys have social security i sold
my mom's condo the beginning of the year
you know that's about a pretty simple
return yeah pretty simple